[Music]
bro code article 35 a bro must never
watch a romantic comedy bro code article
8 a bro must never send a birthday card
to another bro bro code article 41 a bro
never cries the bro code has 125
articles and I first learned about the
bro code available at borough code comm
from Mason a junior in high school I
never met Mason before but he'd agreed
to meet with me or more accurately he'd
had his arm twisted by his mom my former
coworker I've spent the past three
months talking to boys and young men
like Mason I reached out to them because
I wanted to understand what it means to
be a man in 2020 what I found is that
our culture's definition of masculinity
is broken it's outdated it's flawed and
it's emotionally and psychologically
dangerous in the past 50 years in
America we've redefined what it means to
be a woman young girls today are told
that they can do anything be anyone the
author Ruth whitman jokes that if
parents today were naming their children
after virtues like the Puritans used to
do no girls would be named charity or
grace or patients instead half of all
baby girls born in America would be
named empowerment or assertiveness
of course it's still incredibly
difficult to be a woman in 2020 girls
today woman today they face centuries of
prejudices that have calcified over the
years and we're just beginning to chip
away at the surfaces but we're at least
beginning to have nuanced conversations
around what it means to be a woman young
girls today are taught that femininity
can take many different forms our boys
though have been left behind
there are many interpretations of
masculinity and millions of men
subscribe to their own definition but
our culture's predominant definition of
masculinity equates masculinity with
machismo we tell boys to equate
sensitivity with weakness we tell them
to man up to suppress their emotions we
tell them that boys don't cry and tell
him to take it like a man we put our
boys in emotional straitjackets when I
was in high school you could hardly go a
day without hearing the words no homo
when a guy saw another guy in the
hallway he would often maybe hug him and
say no homo just to indicate that in
case anyone was wondering he definitely
isn't gay now the University of Oregon
sociologist CJ Pascoe has actually done
research on no homo sifting through the
more than more than a thousand different
tweets that included the phrase and what
she found is that many of these tweets
simply expressed a positive emotion
something innocuous like I love
chocolate ice cream
hashtag no homo I did my own search
online and I found that many tweets were
from young men to their male friends and
they expressed things like I miss you or
let's hang out soon pasco concluded that
no homo is a form of inoculation against
insults from other guys it's a shield
that allows boys to be fully human now I
want to be clear that this isn't about
sexual orientation as a gay man it's
true that I've been unusually sensitive
to stereotypes around masculinity
in my life but it's also given me a
perspective a different perspective a
view that's unvarnished of our culture's
expectations of manhood meanwhile I've
watched straight friends as well as gay
friends as well as myself suffocate
under the weight of these expectations
in infancy there's no difference between
the sexes need for emotional connection
or in their capacity to show emotion
there's actually some evidence that male
infants are more emotionally expressive
than females but soon that begins to
shift the Harvard psychologist William
[ __ ] notes that by adolescence boys
become shame phobic convinced that peers
will lose respect for them or see them
as lesser if they talk about personal
problems or discuss their feelings the
author Liz Blanc notes that boys have
their gender constantly surveilled for
any side of misstep or mistake boys she
says become fluent in emotional
self-censorship there's a George Orwell
story called shooting an elephant in in
the story there's a colonial policeman
who's tasked with killing an elephant
running wild in his village and he's
told to do it without showing a hint of
hesitation or remorse or regret but he's
torn apart inside the sentence that
Orwell uses to describe how the
policeman felt is he wears a mask and
his face grows to fit it from a young
age our boys wear masks and those masks
soon become how they view themselves
hearted tough unflappable they become
disconnected from the emotions in their
life severed from any intimacy
it's that disconnection that leads to a
loss of empathy speaking with Mason I
was struck by how his language when
talking about girls was rooted in
violence pound
nail hammer woman were dehumanized
objects a means to claim a place in the
hierarchy of masculinity this is
dangerous this disconnection this loss
of empathy it leads to isolation
loneliness desperation leads to men
lashing out 97% of school shootings have
been by men men are three and a half
times as likely as women to kill
themselves
nearly half of domestic violence or
female homicides are the result of
domestic violence of men our boys are
trapped our men are suffocating and they
can't even tell us that they're
suffocating because we haven't allowed
them the emotional vocabulary to cry out
for help so what can we do about it
we can start with our parenting I feel
so lucky to have been raised by my dad
my dad my mom passed away when I was 1
and my dad raised my brother and me on
his own and he is the most emotional and
sensitive man you'll ever meet he cries
like 12 times a day he calls me honey
and my special one every single morning
growing up my dad woke me up by coming
into my room and softly singing here
comes the Sun by the Beatles while
turning on the lights
my dad has shown me that men straight
men can be sensitive and that compassion
and vulnerability form the foundation
for the strongest relationships change
starts with parents parents can
encourage their boys to talk about their
emotions and parents can talk to their
boys about their emotions too in doing
so they can normalize emotional
discourse this is especially important
for fathers and father figures or maybe
it's a male role model or schoolteacher
men need to see motional reciprocal
healthy relationships with boys that
connectivity that's built
on depth in nuance and we can stop
gendering things so much focus has been
on asking women to lean in to speak up
be assertive power pose in the bathroom
before that next big meeting we can also
tell boys to be sensitive to be
vulnerable to listen more we can treat
people as people first and foremost not
as men and women gender today tells us
how to behave instead of letting us
behave in the way that's natural to who
we are
if something's aggressive we can say
that it's aggressive and call it that
not masculine if something's feminine we
can say or something's nurturing we can
say that it's actually just nurturing
and not feminine these categories or
constructions of our culture there's
nothing inherently more masculine about
being brave or strong anymore than
there's anything more inherently
feminine about being gentle or kind we
can rewrite the rules of our culture the
woman's movement has redefined what it
means to be a woman in 2020 it's time we
redefine what it means to be a man thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
you